[Music]
is there something that's very kind of
culturally grounded in terms of the idea
of rightness in in the first place you
mentioned briefly the idea of jainism
and religions and i have to say the idea
of you know multi-polarity or multi you
know multilayeredness strikes me in some
ways like some of the theories of the
universe in which actually we don't have
one reality but multiverses that operate
at the same time depending which you
know reality you're you're you're in so
is that sense of multiplicity
helpful in terms of moving us away from
the idea that there is one sort of
objective reality or is that not the
purpose of that that way of thinking
well i think the jains themselves
thought that they were paradoxically
giving a view of reality as multiple so
they wanted to be able to they were
addressing um this very uh disputatious
and highly pluralistic context of
classical india where because there
wasn't one text that people could agree
on there wasn't sort of one set of
doctrines that people
sort of
were required to interpret
they
what we're trying to find how could you
have a framework in which you are um
epistemically accessible to the other
person
how is it that we don't seem to be able
to agree century after century upon
anything how are you going to reconcile
these features
so
their view was to say well perhaps it's
because
the world this world in which we live
can contain
incompatible troops now i think that
works perhaps better as a kind of a
a
justification for the nature of human
psychology that we're simultaneously
committed to the search for truth and at
the same time baffled by the fact that
we don't seem to be able to agree on too
many things whether that then can become
a program for people to be able to
engage with each other i think that's
going to require certain other kinds of
intellectual virtues which are not
really about the truth but the nature of
our engagement with each other and i
rather suspect that some of our
but santiago and korean might might want
to say more about the way in which the
conditions of agreement have a bearing
on what we accept to be the problem
about truth
okay thanks very much and just say one
thing robin i'm not going to come back
to you on this i want to bring the
others in but just to say in terms of
the definition working today you you
very neatly if i may say it lies at us
from the question of whether things are
right which is what the debate's about
to whether they're true now obviously
there can be a confluence between the
two but of course there is very least a
sort of moral freight on rightness
potentially that uh
i think we do need to tease a part of it
i'm going to turn if i may back to
santiago to do that because if we look
at this question of whether you can
definitively say whether something is
right rather than whether it's true the
two are not incompatible but it's not
actually quite the same question is it
yes you're absolutely right i think it's
right i may be true as well
yeah you're right you're true but only
among each other in other words uh the
huge the question here is that truth is
really a result of our social agreement
we we decide upon ourselves because
uh if we look for example at uh climate
change which is a very good example uh
bruno latour who is a very
important philosopher of science uh
pointed out in his last book that well
fact alone
truth alone right alone does not work it
doesn't it's not sustained uh that's a
problem with fake news and all that so
truth truth alone is we're not gonna do
anything with that he explains in the
book that it's called down to earth in
english
that well you need institutions you need
established newspapers you need
academics you need a whole range of you
need a whole establishment in some way
although we shouldn't work use the word
perhaps establishment in order to
sustain truth being right or facts
so i think it's very important um
to take into consideration that well
uh
truths in some way it's basically what
our you know what our contemporaries let
us get away with in some way so
basically what we
all agree upon in some way
um this is why i think that it's
important to point just one more thing
it's important to point out that
fundamental values are not the result of
a historical development toward truth
but rather an agreement among social
communities
this explains why the history of science
is not a perfect unilineal
history and by the way why but why
why why are we why are we homeless
philosophers going against this why are
we saying these things well a lot of
people think what because because of
some theoretical reasons some some
knowledge we achieved no on the contrary
it's more for an ethical
uh justification in other words if we
look for example someone who explained
this very well it's bauman zigmut bauman
pointed out very clearly that the
problem with this huge rational western
rational um
modernist dream
of embracing this absolute view and
basically of western civilization the
problem with this view
is that genocide follows colonism
follows
you end up by imposing in some way okay
uh a value that perhaps a lot of people
do not want to have now it's very
important and this is really my last
point is that well there are different
levels of truth too if i if i tell you
right now that there's a library behind
me of course we all agree that there is
a library behind me but that from a
theoretical even an ontological point of
view it's very poor i mean it's not a
great statement
if i tell you that it's a beautiful
library well you might disagree and if i
tell you what books i have you might
totally disagree
so
here it's a question that we have to
really take into consideration that
there is no mutual language that we can
all use there are several languages upon
which we should have what i prefer to
call a conversation rather than a
dialogue right a dialogue with something
that plato did ending up by taking the
slave from the cave a conversation is
something more weak that you don't
really know where it's going to end
thanks very much indeed santiago don't
worry we will be coming back to you but
go in i think we seem to be moving in a
direction where we're looking at what's
true
and making that's a subset of of what's
right
do you have yourself a set of
having to use a dangerous word these
days objective standards about how we
can actually define what is true is is
that something we can meaningfully say
can you meaningfully say it
um yeah i think
surprisingly i think it is something we
can mean
meaningfully say and i think you know
both
um santiago and sacramento are going to
agree you know to be her
claim or theory to be true uh then is
just going to be something about you
know correctly describing uh what it's
aiming to describe or uh what it's
talking about
um obviously i take your point about
being true and being right and and there
is a one way to understand being right
has been correct and that sort of
connects up is true in that there is one
way of being right which is more um
uh has to do with other kinds of
knowledge that perhaps you know it has
an ethical dimension which is different
i took it that the debate was about
the first uh uh notion um
i'd like to react to one thing sinchago
said and also one thing that i've
already said that's okay um
so i i do agree with santiago that um
truth you know if you think of a theory
like anthropogenic climate change you
know um it's a very complex thing in
theory and and truth uh is not
everything i agree we think that truth
is not everything i mean
you know uh
there are issues to do with you know
establishing the truth or arguing for
the truth having the right institutions
that enable you to do that and then etc
etc etc um
but true i mean
sometimes you know i mean we should
slide between saying truth is not
everything and truth
is not
does not matter or is not the aim of
the theory or something like that i mean
it might be the case that you know
um truth is not everything but that
doesn't mean that this kind of nothing
or that you know uh truth is not
actually the key
thing that is operating in us looking
for for theories um
so
i think we you know i i'd like to hear
more about about that um i was
interested but
uh by what
he said about incompatible truth and and
that the possibility of there being
uh
you know often we presuppose that there
is just one truth out there and you know
it's a matter of finding it and and then
it appears out you know uh uh uh there
are several truths and and you know they
could they can't all be true um
i think
i would be reluctant to sort of think of
that as a
as something that has to be
you know
taken to hold across the board uh i
think you know you might you know he he
was interested in talking of religious
theories or religious views that's one
thing you know maybe science is another
thing so i think we can you know uh uh
perhaps agree that there are areas where
the idea of a unique truth is you know
has to be revisited or perhaps massaged
in some way but uh we shouldn't think
that because that's the case in all
areas uh uh and and
especially in areas where
we might have better claims
to to think that is
just a unique way the world is then then
we should give up on on there being a
unique uh uh type of truth but but it's
true that you know we there might be
context in which that's different
if i may comment on that so yes that's
exactly what i mean when i said that you
know we have to move away from a
monotonic notion of truth that is to say
that perhaps uh using for example steven
j gould's idea of uh you know magisteria
what we are we might just explain that
idea briefly uh people may not know what
it is yes of course i was just coming to
that yeah so the idea that stephen j
gold was trying to
say how is it that you could have um
religious lives which are coherent and
grounded and driven by particular
claims about knowledge which have no
bearing on or in the case of creationism
perhaps come up against
the theories of evolution and he was
interested also in the fact that many
religious traditions in the world
had no problems with evolution and yet
of course they were not concerned with
finding out
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you